hey everyone its Andrew cash here I'm on
spring break right now
however my due to the coronavirus my
Spring Break plans are actually
cancelled but luckily tidy Tuesday is
not canceled and this week we're
actually looking at a great data set
today so for this week the data set is
the office and it actually comes with
two data sets one called office ratings
which basic contains the episode and
there I am deep rate IMDB ratings and
total votes which really isn't that
interesting however it what's really
cool is that it comes with a package
called the Schrute package which
contains basically all the episodes and
it's dialogue and what's even better
about this data set is it comes with a
dialog with labels specifically
character labels so we have each
character's dialogue for each episode so
what we can do right now and it's what
I'm planning on doing is doing some type
of NLP or text mining project on this
and really the main the main work that
goes into NLP and text mining is
actually getting actually labeling and
getting these labeled data of text data
so since we already had the label data
80% of the work is done for us so we can
kind of jump in and do some fun stuff so
I'm gonna open up our markdown I'm gonna
first call this tidy Tuesday off office
office okay and like all tie a Tuesday
things we're gonna load in the tidy
verse and then we're gonna order in the
Schrute package okay and then we're
gonna say we're just gonna give this the
office data or the main dialogue data to
our data frame called DF so right now
it's a loading for some reason we Louis
or my webcam okay so we're gonna give it
to DF and now we're gonna look at our
actual data frame and see what's going
on
so our data frame contains an index
which is kind of like a row index which
we don't really need a season episode
episode name or episode name an episode
basically the same thing director writer
character text and text with direction
I'm kind of curious on what text and
text with direction are but first let's
kind of look at it in a simple kind of
table view so we'll do DF head now what
I'm noticing right here is there's
notice how season episode an episode
name basically is like these first floor
was it for fields are repeated however
character is making this unique right so
what I'm seeing here let's go to the
next column okay yeah right on so each
observation is literally the characters
dialogue for that scene I think I think
this is a literally the first thing
that's said in the office on episode 1
season 1 so that's that's pretty cool
because it's like almost the entire
conversation for each character so it's
not just the character's text but
characters dialogue for that scene um so
we could actually kind of do like maybe
a time series if we really wanted to
using an index so we could see like Oh
Michael's sentiment ah throughout the
season but let's let's not get ahead of
ourselves and start let's start kind of
looking at some basic summary statistics
so first we should see which is count
let's just count how many characters
there are so I'm gonna do select season
episode and then character character
okay and we're gonna count we're gonna
do the unique function because notice
how these characters are duplicating but
if we do season episode character and we
find the unique character a unique
values for this
we're basically Dulli all duplicates and
then if we count character we're
essentially counting how many times a
character has showed up and eat for an
episode so it's saying how many episodes
is a character in
we'll also apply this secondary command
which just sorta khals true just this
sort account and we can see that okay
Dwight was in a 186 episodes which makes
sense cause he's the main character Jim
Pam Kevin yeah those are all the main
characters and one thing that I want to
kind of do first is if we're gonna
analyze some characters we don't want to
analyze 773 characters we want to
analyze I guess the main characters so
I'm gonna do a basic summary statistics
first just to see what see how many did
the distribution of episode appearances
so our distribution is basically third
quartile says there's one which means
that most people most characters only
appear once if more than once then the
character is probably a I guess a show
regular right because we can see how the
mean is five point eight one eight and
the meeting is one so its heavily skewed
and we can we can visualize that too so
let's do let's do a visualization of it
okay and what's - a ggplot yes X we'll
just do y equals and Jim boxplot and I
bet we'll need to do some
transformations right so we're
definitely need to do a transformation
so we'll do a scale Y log 10 we'll do a
log 10 transformation and what do we see
here we see most of it is that one
however most of our outliers are all the
way over here so what we're going to do
also is we're gonna just filter n is
greater than 1 so we're going to just
filter out we're gonna filter out
characters who have only appeared in one
episode so they has appear and more
and there we go so most of our
characters between q1 and q3 for
observations are around to this a right
to day cool so we don't need to worry
about that um well I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna select count sort and now we're
gonna we're gonna try to decide what
characters we want to just analyze for
our dialogue and I'm actually to use
some domain knowledge for this because
I've watched the office at DC my own
time plan Netflix and I know that these
first 10 characters are the main
characters and I believe that their
dialogue is very valuable for an
analysis so we're gonna go to 11 through
20 and again all these characters make
sense for the for the episode
appearances so we're gonna keep these
Nellie I'm not too sure about keeping
but we're just gonna keep her and then
we're gonna working out a 21 to 30 and
right here for 21 or 30 we can see that
it gets a little hazy where all these
characters I would say are not as
important although I do like Pete as a
character we're just gonna ignore it so
just I'm gonna select character and to
select basically the one the first 20
characters I'm gonna use a slice
function and sue slice 1 through 20
which will basically pick the rows 1
through 20 and we'll call this
characters caret characters cool okay so
now we finally have a character's and
important characters that we want to use
but we also want to look at let's look
at the let's look at the writers first
so I'm gonna select season episode
writer unique unique and then I'll do
count writer I would say sort equals
true okay
cool so our top top three writers who
wrote the most episodes are Mindy Kaling
BJ Novak and Paul Lieberstein which is
pretty cool because those are also
characters on the office they are both
actors and writers okay but one thing
I'm also noticing is that right here
this is this is like a multi value
attribute where there had they had
multiple writers writing for that
episode so I'm kind of curious like what
what writer duo's like where the most
frequent writer pairings in the office
so what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna do a
filter and we'll say ser detect writer
and so we know our multivalued
attributes are delimited by a semicolon
we can say filter all were crazy trying
to filter any writers that contain the
semicolon so we're going to do that and
there we go we have our pairings and
we'd see the majority of the writers are
the most popular duo is gene and Ally
and we're also running in a problem for
Louie and gene are our count as separate
people but that's fine we know it's like
about 13 of the episodes were written by
this duo that's pretty cool so when I'm
going to comment gene and we wrote as a
duo wrote a lot of episodes episodes
together okay cool
so we kinda did a preliminary analysis
now let's actually kind of get into some
text mining so I'm gonna actually load
up the tidy text package which is kind
of which is a text mining package that
really follows the tidy verse
fundamentals so now we're gonna do
something where we're gonna use the uh
nest tokens function and we'll use the
output as word and our input is text and
what this is saying is we're gonna
remove all of the dialogue and convert
it to just words okay see all right Jim
your queries look very fun
so it basically converts it to one
single value you know if you if you can
even consider sentences as a collection
of words it's basically a multivalued
attribute so now we're resolving this
multi value attribute constraint and
change it to a single value attributes /
observation or per row cool so I'm gonna
say I'm gonna call us a word DF so we
don't have to go through anything
actually you went I'm gonna do something
something a little bit different and I'm
gonna do
unless tell cam also gonna do count and
no no I'm gonna do it I'm gonna come
just gonna make out a word DF we don't
have to do anything this is to make it
basically a little bit more um flexible
for analysis so we created our word DF
and now what we can do is count
character and by word coolest and so
what I'm saying right now is for every
character we're gonna count the words
and the word frequencies however what we
also need to do is do a inner join with
our characters to filter out the the
relevant characters who want to analyze
it's now is only choosing characters
that were inside our characters um data
frame great so we're just gonna do a
group by character
top oops top and and and n equals I so
we're finding the top five words for
each character okay
and then we're just gonna cheat you plot
it out so x equals word y equals and cup
fill equals character genome com+ cord
flip plus facet wrap cuz we are doing
basically we're making a column chart
showing the top five words and we're
making multiple charts for each
character and we're flipping the axis
because it's easier to read for the
corresponding words so we're gonna do
that okay so you can see how you can see
how it's not very great because all we
see is you to the I a as the most
frequent words for all the characters
and there's a problem with counting just
words and not doing any type of
filtering because these words that we're
seeing right now are called stop words
what's great though is that tidy text
actually contains um a way to remove
stop words by using the anti join and
we'll say stop words right okay and what
and what we're using anti join is we're
just saying that if these words if you
share these values in the stop words
list will just remove it so it's a
really quick way to remove remove our
filter out on words that you don't want
cool sending on we have this if you
notice that these things aren't really
ordered to correctly we'd rather order
it for by like descending order
luckily tidy text actually has another
way to order it very easily so we'll use
the reorder within word and character
right and then we'll do a plus scale X
reordered
okay and now we'll run that and I'm
going to do some basic code cleanup okay
so now we're gonna try to analyze top
five words for each character we're
moving stop words cool I'm actually
gonna make this a little bit bigger so
dot high it goes 15 fig with equals
equals 15 sweet okay sweet we're just
gonna go kind of one by one we can see
that Andy is still most frequent word
removing stop words is yeah now you
could say that yeah is a stop word and
you just add it to it if we really
wanted to but I'm trying to keep it I'm
not gonna do any micro adjustments I'm
just gonna let tight X and just do the
out-of-the-box analysis on it okay so we
can see that yeah and Michael are very
popular words yeah Jim God Ryan Michael
Dwight okay so one trick with this is we
can actually use the term frequency by
emerged Ockman frequency first when I
say top five words with stop word
removal what we're really trying to look
for is not the most frequent words that
are decided by two characters but what
are the most distinguished full words
for each character and that's where
tf-idf really stands out so actually I
can just kind of add this bad boy on
alright okay and we're gonna use tf-idf
which is called term frequency by
inverse document frequency and what this
finds is basically it basically come
balances how frequent aware it is and
how rare award is within groups and
within groups is basically within the
characters so we're trying to find a
word that is used most by we're trying
to find a word that is used a lot by one
character and one character only so
we're going to do the vine tf-idf we'll
say word our document is character enter
n is n boom okay and we're going to do a
group by character top oops
top n tf-idf n equals 5 ungroup ungroup
and I'm just gonna copy this thing right
here cuz I don't really feel like typing
this all over again you could make this
in a function however it gets a little
weird it gets a little fuzzy when you're
using GG plots and functions so I'm just
gonna kind of copy and paste in however
you could create your own function where
you're you can specify your N and what's
going on here on top and tf-idf ooh
there you go you already know I had to
change this fig height someone's you
know fig dot height equals 15 fade with
goes 15 okay okay let's see what its
gonna output there we go so now we can
see and here right right here we're
seeing something that's really
interesting tuna is Andy's most
essential word because he says tuna the
most I don't think a single character
besides Andy says tuna okay Creed
Bratton
no one says creed bratton besides Creed
Brian right Dwight always says his last
name says sensei um let's see what else
is kind of interesting Erin
and lice pretty interesting so right
here at Gabe's Gabe has hadass hit us so
that might be an error with our
tokenization but we don't have to worry
about that right now
what is second-most this thing was just
singing for does Chow which is
definitely a very iconic word from cool
and then Ryan it's wolf timeline pesto
Drake silicon-silicon let's here Michael
it's Jan Hawley Packer uh Oscar it's
senator very interesting Pam her most
distinct short is Cece because she's
that's her daughter
Jim and Pam's daughter cool
so we now now we can see that it the
difference between top-5 tf-idf words
and top top five most frequent is just
nine day right tf-idf within groupings
just is the superior method for
analyzing um tokens especially when
you're trying to find things that
distinguish each grouping okay
so what else we want to do I'm thinking
that we should do a sentiment analysis
by a time series that'd be pretty cool
so we're knew that okay so we're gonna
do our word e at first okay and with our
wordy if we're gonna do a inner we're
gonna do a select index character and
then we'll say word okay and then we're
gonna do a inner join by characters cool
and then we're gonna do a we're gonna
use another inner join and this is how
you do a basic sentiment analysis using
tiny text say inner join get sentiments
lexicon oops
equals and we'll say Bing
okay Bing so what that what this is
doing is basically a lexicon is a
dictionary that's been kind of available
to as what are we saying are positive
words what we're saying you're negative
words so when we see so in the Bing
lexicon the Bing lock sound believes the
word good is a positive word the word
right well like our positive words the
word sorry is a negative word okay and
now we're gonna actually just kind of
and when it joins it together it's
saying like it has a a word and it's
sentiment and if it finds that word they
don't just pair it up with this
sentiment and I'll just remove anything
that doesn't have any sentiment cool
okay so now what we're gonna do is we're
going to do a group by index and
character and we're going to do a count
sentiment so now for every episode for
each character we're counting the
sentiment for each episode the total
assessment for each all the dialogue
okay we're going to ungroup that and
we're going to G do pot a yes x equals
and once the x equals index oops
y equals n color equals actually we'll
say y equals n color equals character
plus G ohm point plus G yeah which is G
um point plus facet wrap and we'll say
sentiment so what this is gonna
hopefully do is it's gonna create two
plots where each character will have its
own points representing color of the
positive negative sentiment trends and
I'm just doing gene point first just to
make sure everything looks right okay
what are we seeing here this is pretty
much a mess right I'm curious maybe it
isn't the best to do by character maybe
we should do it by season so we're gonna
select by season okay and then we'll
just do group by season and index and
okay I got a better idea we'll just do
first this okay and then with ggplot a
yes
x equals season and I got an idea we'll
do a little mutate will do a mutate
episode will say episode index equals
pace index and season except maybe
actually no I think I think I'll be fine
we'll say ggplot aes x equals index y
equals and color equals season plus
giome point plus facet wrap and we'll
say sentiment scales equals free let's
see what that looks like
okay so our positive-negative sudden it
looks priests and actually I'm gonna do
it scales equals fixed so we can do it
an easier comparison and I'm gonna do a
Geum smooth ice equals false and then
what's your group equals sentiment
hopefully this will show me some type of
pretty fun so it's smoothing doesn't
really do a lot there's kind of a it's
kind of a nightmare for it interesting
here's here's one thing that I think
that would be a little bit easier to
understand what do a will do a Geum
boxplot and instead of will say boom
season what was going on here
he has X equal season y equals and
Oh
what why is it not showing you this set
let's see what's going on here okay
GG pump in with your GG pot oh yes oh
yeah we'll just uh actually yeah we'll
just do what is do centered per season
this seems like an easier way to do this
so we'll do select season group by group
by season count sentiment ungroup boom
and then we can do a ggplot AS x equals
season y equals and color equals
sentiment giome point plus GM smooth
okay and then we'll say group equal
ascent see right here is a much the this
is the thing there where i was really
kind of overthinking it and thinking
that I should do a very very specific
very detailed chart when in reality we
can see this overall scent bin right
here right but a problem with this chart
is that sentiment is just on a frequency
of words so some seasons might have more
words that have just been said right so
we're gonna have to do is we're gonna
have to do some type of standardization
right so my few sentiment per word and
now that'll be pretty easy we can just
do that pretty quickly so we're gonna do
that I'm gonna select and then we're
gonna say count C's add add count per
season
and then oh and then we're gonna do a
we're gonna ruminating that too
and as was a season count what was ad
count I do it and count season and then
we'll say name equals season word count
right okay and then we'll say inner join
get sentiment lexicon equals Bing and
then we'll say group by seasoned count
word Oh Count count sentiment I will say
add count sentiment on group select
season and we'll say we'll just do it
just a mutate N equals actual say
sentiment score equals n divided by
season word count right and then we'll
say select season sentiment and
sentiment score unique salt season wrong
right and then we'll do a ggplot yes x
equals season Michael sentiment score
color equals sentiment geom point plus
genome smooth IC equals a false and you
want I bet we're going to do a group
equal sentiment too
just to make sure ggplot isn't confused
and I'll make sure to this time we'll do
fig dot height equals 15 fade out with
equals 15 oh and then I do like comma
okay
why is my plot doing this there we go
and we see that it's still the same
thing this thing is way too large so
I'll do 10 right and we see that overall
honestly it's it still is playing the
same picture where Center positive
sentiment is much higher than negative
sentiment however it stays pretty
stagnant right I would say maybe maybe
deposit Center has decreased a little
bit but it's still not enough where I
would say that it's a big deal cool okay
so what else are should we be doing um
let's see here let's create let's
analyze three characters three of the
main characters okay so we're going to
do oops word D F and we're gonna select
the index character and word and we're
going to filter character to be either
Michael Dwight and and Jim okay and
just gonna make sure that we selected
the right characters Michael Dwight Jim
okay and what we're gonna do is we're
gonna do a different lexicon we're gonna
do uh get sentiment lexicon equals and
we're gonna use the NRC lexicon instead
oops and I totally get sentiments oh I
could wrap an inner join inner join get
sentiments right now we're gonna do a
first of all a group by character index
at count word name equals or Cena call
it out word count just to not confuse it
word count and then we're also gonna
count sentiment oh we're not Attic at
another count and say sentiment okay so
now we have the sentiment for that for
the episode okay okay and RC yet let's
see I'm just making sure that all the
sentient makes sense cool okay
okay and we're going to select index
character sentiment actually what we're
gonna do a mutate first and we'll say
mutate sentiment sentiment score equals
and divide by a word count okay
select carat index character oops
sentiment sentiment score okay ggplot a
yes x equals index y equals sentiment
score color equals sentiment giome point
plus genome smooth s equals we'll say s
equals false for now plus facet wrap
because we want to view all the
characters first character and we'll say
scales
oops scales scales equals fixed so now
we're channel looking we're trying to
get a basically a time series of
sentiment school assessment for each
character and this is through their
dialogue so like oh is Jim saying more
positive stuff throughout the season or
he just kind of staying consistent is
Michael saying happier stuff or you say
more angry stuff oh okay just that I
gotta do one more thing
and then we'll actually say a group
equals interaction character and
sentiment and that group Eagles okay
let's see let's see if this actually
works first but let's hear it's it's
taken a while okay a fig with equals ten
fig dot equals ten
mmm-hmm okay so we couldn't do a crazy
interaction that's pretty interesting
okay you know what we might have to add
another sentiment I'm gonna I'm gonna
actually do another facet so I want to
do character for each individual
sentiment actually no I'm gonna do
something else I'm gonna do if you see
right here it's a mess there's way too
many sentiments or so I'm gonna do it
for each sentiment the color will be the
character and then the interaction will
be character in sentiment hopefully this
will fix everything so it makes it look
fine
okay let's see what's going on here
interesting well we can see that Michael
was saying a lot more anticipation a lot
of anticipation words or words that were
ranked Roy high we see just overall
michael has a highest sentiment in
general and we see on the upper plane
areas you always see blue right so I'm
gonna actually do another transformation
so I'll do scale why log10 okay and
after this we'll go onto an another
thing because I'm sure he has a tired of
looking at these these sentiment scores
okay
so it's kind of is a mess let's I really
man oh well we'll be fine with this but
actually I think I'm I [ __ ] I want to do
one more thing I think I'm gonna do it
instead of index goodbye episode episode
and we'll do episode at this episode I
one more time and then we'll call it I
don't know if this will change anything
anyways it can't absolute while it's
doing this we're gonna move on to
another thing finally what I want to
analyze is let's figure out what are the
catch phrases so what are the
distinguishing or catch phrases for each
character and when I say distinguishing
for each character that should just
right now pop-up tf-idf so we're going
to select character and text and then
we're going to do the on nest tokens
okay there we go
interesting again so now it did make it
a little bit easier better technically
the index when I did by episode I
should've done AB set index instead but
we can see that overall michael has
higher sentiment in general cool okay
I'm kind of I'm kind of over this now so
we're gonna select the character text
we're gonna do the inner join by
character characters and now what we're
gonna do is we're gonna use bind tf-idf
and this time instead of oops not bind
TFI if we'll do get uh nestings on nest
tokens and our output will be engrams
since we're gonna do an Engram analysis
our input is text our token equals
engrams and we're gonna say our N equals
four right we'll do four actually no
will do and we'll do I want to do I'll
do multiples so it would be three and
want to say trigram three actually yeah
try again DF and then we'll say count
count character and grams so we'll say
we'll call this a trigram because it's
pairing of three words and then we'll
call this a Quadron which will be a
pairing of four words
so four and then we'll do a quoi
was it a Kim Cuong
I think it's quant gram so we'll just
call it quantum and we'll call us five
oops okay so this is still running for
some reason we'll run that anyway I've
already said I'm not gonna do five five
gram that that's a little excessive so
with our trigram since we already have
our trigram we'll do a a TF by a bind
tf-idf and we'll say it's our engrams
character and n was a group by character
and we'll say top and tf-idf N equals
three ungroup boom we'll do the same
thing for the quad Ram
okay let's see what's still running okay
there we go okay and we'll call that
will call this trigram again try ooo try
try again
okay and quad grant will be the same
thing right there okay and then we'll do
it we'll assign our quad ram too and
finally we'll do a mutate so mutate
actually no we'll just what is plotted
out so ggplot guess x equals reorder
within engrams tf-idf and we'll say
character and then we'll say y equals
tf-idf and then we'll say fill Oh fill
equals character plus giome column plus
scale X reordered scale X reordered plus
facet wrap character scales equals free
and actually I'm going to do a core flip
- boom try again a trigram
so what we're doing right now is finding
the groupings of three words three words
and doing a tf-idf so fiying what what's
free word groupings distinguish each
character and we're defining the top
three or groupings okay what's going on
here okay I got a a fig dot dot height
equals 15 fig width equals 15 and there
we have it right nard dog is the most
distinguishable word for Andy pom-pom
and the Senators the senator Nana
so that's when he was singing that song
Dwight Dwight sure it is Dwight Schrute
Jan's
Michael Jim's is a women away along the
way it's here
Kevin's is warning for some reason Pam
is this is Pam okay what I'm curious is
let's look so these are the distinguish
alike catchphrases I guess for for those
characters but I want to look at instead
of trigrams I want to look at the quad
Graham's someone will get a quad Graham
first and the quad ram might run into
some issues I want to first look at just
see how many rows there are so 173
here's how to find it I kind of like do
a quick and dirty way to filter it so
we'll say a group by character arranged
by descending tf-idf slice 1 2 3 group
ohso why my group by slice one through
three so that way it's saying like okay
we're taking the top three tf-idf scores
even if there is a tie we're gonna
select whatever is the first three okay
um and that's basically how you like
resolve ties really fast or how I do it
really fast but you can also specify and
like top end on its where's how it
resolves ties but I really don't know
how to do that so we're gonna do this
and then we're gonna apply this function
and okay and I told you that fig dot
height equals 15 fig dot width equals 15
got a restart I'm not sure why I might I
mean this laptops pretty bad so it's
gonna be nice well um it renders it
pretty slowly but okay boom boom boom
blah blah blah I'm gonna do that do that
I'm gonna a couple bucks
so what's funny about daryl is it's the
nah-nah-nah song for Dwight his most
iconic things dis is white shirt was
answering the phone um again Erin Dunder
Mifflin this is Erin Andy's coming back
today
interesting um what's here again with
Jim it's a one bit one way The Lion King
song that's pretty cool okay I want you
to be pp let's see what else again with
Pam Dunder Mifflin this is Pam was when
she was a receptionist nope nope no
that's funny you lost your mind have you
lost your mind okay so we found his
catchphrases for each character each
character
top three catchers okay well I hope this
helped everyone kind of just get their
dip their toes in a text mining this is
really kind of how I do a preliminary
basic EDA
whenever you text and it's actually very
useful and what's really cool about text
mining is that it's very new so all
these techniques are still being
developed and you know sometimes text
mining is both an art and a science
where you know it really you really do
need some domain knowledge to understand
what is saying here who's who's the user
who's saying this text what it was
where are they actually meeting for what
are they meeting to say and also how
sometimes I simply just count awards can
really get you pretty far um so yeah
hopefully this helped everyone um I'll
see you next week and yeah Teddy Allen